je vais vous répondre très volontiers
mais c'est vrai que c'est difficile
d'annuler des chiffres après un
témoignage mais c'est important et ça
prouve que en fait les Européens sont
solidaires du courageux peuvent
ukrainien à qui on a décerné ce prix
sacrophe aujourd'hui l'aide de l'Union
européenne c'est 2,2 milliards d'aide
que la pelle macro financière pour
soutenir directement l'Ukraine dans ses
actions et à côté pour que l'économie
ukrainienne puisse continuer à
fonctionner tout simplement qu'on puisse
payer les fonctionnaires on a donné
également 350 millions d'aide
humanitaires parce qu'il y a aussi des
populations déplacées à l'intérieur de
l'Ukraine qu'il faut pouvoir aider et
puis 3,1 milliard de de facilité pour la
paix c'est comme ça qu'on l'appelle qui
permet de fournir des armes défensives à
l'Ukraine qui permet aussi de livrer du
carburant de livrer des des premiers
secours d'accompagner à la hauteur
justement vis-à-vis de ça parce que on
sent cette attente très forte en
particulier le président Zelinski qui
réclame des armes à corps et à cri on a
l'impression que ce sont quand même
beaucoup les Américains qui livrent des
armes est-ce que l'Union européenne est
à la hauteur la France va livrer
d'autres canons César par exemple oui on
est à la hauteur parce que en fait on
n'a jamais fait autant d'efforts
les Européens avaient un peu une sorte
de pudeur vis-à-vis de la défense
c'était pas trop le sujet qui était mis
en avant par les 27 et aujourd'hui il y
a cette solidarité il y a cette envie de
défendre nos valeurs en Ukraine en fait
parce que ce que ce pourquoi se battre
les Ukrainiens ce sont nos valeurs et
donc avec 3,1 milliard déjà corps aussi
500 millions d'euros qui vont être
réattribués pour refaire des stocks
d'armes dans l'Union européenne parce
que on a tellement donné
qu'on en a plus donc presque plus quand
même pas non plus exagéré mais il va
falloir effectivement refaire des stocks
pour être prêt également à affronter
l'avenir si vous passez on n'a jamais
fait autant au niveau de la défense
peut-être déjà le bien bien le préciser
il y a tous les États membres qui à côté
en plus de ces milliards que j'ai évoqué
amène aussi des armes amènent aussi des
des solutions
c'est important de le rappeler on n'a
jamais fait ça donc il y a une prise de
conscience européenne je crois que si on
arrête de parler de l'Europe de la
défense et si on parlait un peu plus de
la défense de l'Europe je pense que ce
serait plus facile de créer une soudé
chez
entreamans pour aller plus de l'avant
alors cette fois ce que vous appelez une
formation en fait qui est une mission
d'assistance on joue un peu sur les mots
c'est 105 millions d'euros et qui ont
été mobilisés pour former 15000 soldats
Ukrainiens dans en Pologne si j'ai bien
compris certains en Allemagne en
Allemagne mais aussi en Belgique en
France ou en fait on va apprendre le
métier de soldat quelque part parce
qu'il y aura des professionnels il y
aura aussi des conséquences
et puis le problème aussi de ces guerres
qui malheureusement durent sur plusieurs
mois c'est que il faut aussi sans arrêt
remettre à niveau reformer les les
personnels militaires parce qu'il peut
aussi avoir une sorte de fatigue y
compris morale donc c'est extrêmement
important de pouvoir ressourcer reformer
pour qu'ils effectivement des
combattants aguerris qui puissent se
trouver sur le sur le théâtre
d'opération en Ukraine puisque je
rappelle que 100% de la guerre se
déroule sur le territoire je suis plutôt
d'accord en effet en effet notre
autonomie énergétique européenne elle
est indispensable à la maîtrise de notre
avenir aujourd'hui on dépend à 64%
d'énergie qui viennent d'autres
continents donc il y a vraiment quelque
chose d'important à mettre en place le
green il peut d'ailleurs parfaitement
avec le tribué puisque les énergies
renouvelables peuvent se produire en
Europe le nucléaire peut aussi se
produire en Europe avec une autonomie de
6 à 8 ans donc on a on a des solutions
en interne pour moins dépendre et on va
pas arrêter de dépendre du gaz russe
pour dépendre du gaz de schiste
américain et un moment il faut aussi
être cohérent et tirer des leçons voilà
et et par contre cette question
d'énergie c'est centrales pour l'avenir
de notre soutien l'Ukraine parce que en
fait il y a une solidarité des
populations une solidarité de tout le
monde vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine par contre
tu peux vous assurer que si demain un
certain nombre d'Européen n'ont pas
d'électricité pour s'éclairer en hiver
non pas de quoi chauffer parce que à
cause des sanctions on s'est privé de
gaz russe c'est un élément là les
peuples risquent de se retourner
monsieur Poutine ne sait bien d'ailleurs
donc pour ça qu'il travaille de
communication
autour des prix d'énergie etc donc en
fait on a un devoir nous en tant qu'Euro
député avec l'ensemble des institutions
et des États membres on a le devoir
d'agir pour maintenir actuellement
l'augmentation des prix et prévoir très
rapidement la baisse des prix c'est
vital pour pouvoir continuer notre
soutien donc il y a une mobilisation
générale là-dessus avec le capage des
prix avec peut-être demain alors ça sera
peut-être un an ou deux pour
restructurer le marché séparer le prix
de l'électricité du prix du gaz il y a
certains nombre de mesures qui peuvent
être prises effectivement axes sur les
distribué au ménage et aux entreprises
effectivement qui en ont le plus besoin
et peut-être aussi rappeler que
l'Ukraine en ce moment est en train est
en passe d'être privé d'électricité